voilà je l'aimais arrivé au mali et
l'idée c'est d'aller dormir chez les
gens je sais pas qui ça c'est très
premier épisode de la série j'irai
dormir chez vous et depuis j'ai parcouru
une soixantaine de pays
alors bien sûr ici j'étais vraiment
compliqué
et du coup je me suis souvent demandé ce
qui se passerait si un jour ça dérapait
vraiment antoine de maximy nos
présentateurs de j'irai dormir chez vous
a disparu alors qu'il était en tournage
dans les carpates plaisante agnès la
menteuse d'antoine lieutenant laurent
logis nos logis et ont rapporté à faire
d'antoine oui il ya beaucoup de matériel
et pas mal de casse at il manque deux
cassettes
j'ai peut-être d'antoine qui les a
perdus coucou quand le premier jour tout
le monde que le fait d'être là comme ça
c'est un langage qui démarre bien avant
la ligne d'arrivée à branne dans les
contreforts des carpates dit toujours le
plus important s'il m'arrive quelque
chose c'est vous finissez le film j'ai
envie d'aller vers le nord je sais pas
su retracer bien là depuis qu'il est
arrivé dans le nord des carpates
il a du mal avec les gens rami lévy
bourgeois
si ce n'était pas un accident dans la
nièce
tard et j'ai l'impression que c'est
quelque chose de bizarre là non mais
pour avancer il faut des preuves
le 7 août dracula s'il vous plaît est-ce
que je peux dormir chez vous savez bregy
c'est quand même très bizarre de faire
ce genre de geste discrètement là on
dirait qu'ils complotent
voyant pitt élaborent vous croyez qu'on
pourrait le retrouver qui pourrait être
encore vivant